[Musique]
c'est dans mon lit les
11h mal au cœur
mal envie de
pipi
déjeuner mon
café la
radio c'est trop c'est pas bon ouais
fais pas
chaud me
laver me
raser
m'habiller me
peigner mes
cheveux bien coiffé
ouais les
midi mes
parents sont rentrés en
criant faut manger après travailler et
les 2 he
un chum un je Poé un petit
mi dans mon cœur il y a plein de douleur
ouais je
t'appelle je m'en
vais mon
café à côté ouais il y a des filles il y
a des fliip
ouais les 20h ah ah faut dîner
ah oh ma maman ah ah ah cuisiné ah ah ah
ah pas ouais la télé oui il est tard
je
mes idées
son
bouill oh je me
couche je
dors c'est
Mar dans mon
lit les
midi je
fuis ce
ou
[Musique]
c'est
jeudi
vendredi samedi ouais c'est
dimanche
mon dans
mon
sal merci
Monsieur Jess Garon pas
[Musique]
mal